foreign
moving on our main story tonight
concerns Antiquities basically relics
from bygone times that can tell us
stories about people from the past like
your nana but less overtly racist
specifically our story concerns what
happens when those relics go missing and
I'll start by giving you just one
example if you go to Greece you might go
to the Acropolis Museum and while you're
marveling at sculptures they're over two
Millennia old you might notice some odd
details like this sculpture which
appears to have a white foot or this one
where someone's whole upper half seems
to be suddenly and overwhelmingly white
it's what's known in the art world as
season two of The Wire well there is an
explanation for where those missing
pieces are and as a British person I'm a
little bit implicated so the darker
stone is the original whereas this white
Plaster that represents what's in the
British museum exactly
and here it is in the British museum the
missing marble head and chest floating
in a display space
yeah you took it honestly if you are
ever looking for a missing artifact nine
times out of ten it's in the British
museum it's basically the world's
largest lost and found with both lost
and found in the heaviest possible
quotation marks there
specifically those marbles known in
England as the Elgin marbles were taken
by Lord Elgin a 19th century British
Lord who hacked them off the Parthenon
it's something that the Greeks are
understandably Furious about because
they weren't lost they were taken which
is clearly worse it's like being unable
to find the last puzzle piece and
learning that you didn't actually
misplace it a British Earl snuck into
your house stole it and then sold it to
a museum over a thousand miles away
Greece has been demanding the return of
the Elgin marbles for decades now but
the response from some of the British
Museum's Defenders has been even by
British standards unbelievably
patronizing
can't even think about returning the
elegant marbles to Athens until the
Greeks start caring for what they
already have
sure they'd take great care of the path
and sculptures if they were returned but
if you knew a woman was abusing her
child he wouldn't let her adopt another
and that's what the Greeks were asking
for what that is not a great comparison
especially because it admits the fact
that the woman's child in this example
was basically kidnapped so it's less a
woman asking to adopt another child than
it is her demanding the return of her
first one and look the Parthenon marbles
should absolutely be returned to Greece
even that woman you just saw now says
that she thinks they should go back but
those marbles are just the tip of the
iceberg here the fact is Antiquities
largely from the global South which
includes Latin America Africa Asia and
the Mideast have been taken and
enshrined in European and American
museums on a much larger scale than you
may realize in 2018 a report
commissioned by the French President
found that over 90 percent of all
Africa's cultural heritage is held
outside Africa by Major museums but the
voices arguing for Antiquities to be
returned are getting louder others are
resisting any change in 2010 when asked
whether the UK would ever return the
coin or Diamond to India prime minister
David Cameron refused saying if you say
yes to one you suddenly find the British
museum would be empty which is
incredibly frustrating and it's frankly
no wonder that some are now taking
matters into their own hands in June the
Congolese activists removed a 19th
century charging funeral pool from the
kebahani museum in Paris as part of a
protest campaign against plundering
during the colonial era yeah that
happened and obviously that man was
unaware of the Museum's very clear
policy No Stealing African Antiquities
starting now
so given just how many Antiquities in
some of the world's most prestigious
museums are essentially stolen goods
tonight let's talk about museums and
this is going to be a larger story than
normal and we're going to do it in two
main parts first concerning how
Antiquities ended up in museums in the
past and then about the thriving modern
Market that keeps them supplied with
objects to this very day and look we
don't have time to recap the entire
history of colonialism and the plunder
of Antiquities there are so so many
stolen artifacts that we could talk
about tonight from the treasures of tipu
Sultan to the Zodiac of dendera but in
order to say a lot in a little let's
stay with the British museum in its own
promotional materials it makes a big
feature of just how important and
influential its founding was
in January 1759 the British museum
opened its doors the first national
public Museum of the world initially the
objects were based on the founding
collection of Sir Han Sloan and this is
Han Sloan
scholar entrepreneur
physician who was connected with the
best minds of his time
in fact
our collection has always been about
Connecting People okay
first I'm going to say what we're all
thinking that guy has definitely Googled
Good Night at the Museum actually happen
not because he's scared of a big bony
dinosaur chasing him but because when no
one is around he definitely [ __ ] the
art and he definitely doesn't want any
of it talking but
that notion of museums is a place for
people to connect with our shared
history with cultures all over the world
clearly isn't fundamentally bad but it's
also not wholly representative of the
actual history of how many museums came
to be for instance Han Sloan who on his
best day looked like that had some
interesting connections of his own
specifically the fact that he was
married to an heiress to Sugar
plantations in Jamaica worked by
enslaved people and bought many objects
in his collection with that wealth
meaning that the Museum's very
foundations are inextricably tied up in
slavery and colonialism with the same
being true of many of its most prized
Holdings take the Benin bronzes it's a
term that refers to a huge range of
objects produced in the Kingdom of Benin
which is currently part of modern day
Nigeria now the Benin bronzes were
looted from the Palace of the king of
Benin or the Oba in 1897 after the
British military invaded and violently
toppled him that mission was vindictive
and it was destructive but it was also
extremely targeted the British soldiers
armed with machine guns conquered the
city and burned it to the ground but not
before carefully taking thousands of
artifacts they piled them up neatly
photographed them and even labeled them
loot this photo taken at the Benin
Palace after the raid shows Soldiers
with the dismantled plaques that were
brought to the British Museum and sold
all over the world okay first that's
obviously awful but second it is pretty
remarkable that a British soldier went
to the trouble of carefully labeling
each of those photos and the captions he
used were Loot and more loot
at the very least you could have chosen
something more descriptive like I don't
know Dan Terry and I after doing
cultural genocide
but the Looting of the Benin brontes
wasn't just a physical loss it was a
cultural and historical one take these
plaques they are not just pieces of art
they're something much more important as
this member of the Benin royal family
explained those things are like our own
values
or whatever was significant the other
would tell the Guild of bronze casters
to cast it in promise
to keep a record
so taking them away was like yanking off
pages of our history right for that
Kingdom these were their memories made
physical and these plaques were laid out
in a very specific order which was then
lost when the British tore them from the
palace walls meaning the British in
effect stole and scrambled a nation's
memories a crime so [ __ ] up even Black
Mirror hasn't thought of it yet
the bronzes are currently scattered
among 161 museums and institutions
around the world with only nine such
institutions located in Nigeria and
understandably there have been calls for
the return of the bronzies for decades
now and a handful of museums have
complied but the British museum which
holds more branches than anyone has
repeatedly refused pointing to the
British museum Act of 1963 which
explicitly forbids it from giving an
item in its collection away with very
limited exceptions and the thing is that
law does exist but laws can also be
changed if you want to and the more you
hear British officials talk the clearer
it becomes that that is not what they
want at all well I think that they
properly reside in the British museum
the collections of our great National
institutions have been developed over
many many centuries in many times in uh
questionable circumstances I think the
question now is about what we do with
these I love the Benin bronzes I've seen
them many times throughout my life and I
think them being in the British museum
which is a world repository of Heritage
allows people to see it yeah that
offensively English man loves the Benin
branches and while I'm so glad that
Oliver James Dowden MP for heart smear
has seen them many times throughout his
life the fact is not everyone gets to do
that as this Nigerian artist and art
historian will attest 1995.
in London
that was my first time of seeing an
original
uh ancient Benin
artwork was yes at the British museum to
see for the first time in these objects
it was a mixture of pride in their
achievement of these ancient artists and
anger mixed with a sense of loss most
Nigerians will never see them exactly
the generations of British children
who've grown up loving the Benin bronzes
come at the expense of generations of
Nigerians who haven't and again this is
just one example of so so many and
whenever the question of returning
stolen objects comes up there are
usually a few stock responses which are
worth quickly addressing the first is
basically that these were acquired in a
different time and you can't judge the
present by the standards of the past
when France was recently broiled by a
debate over whether to return African
art this catastrophically French art
historian basically made that exact case
these artifacts who do they belong to
they belong to the museum where they are
now because there are laws you know and
if even for the the artifacts which were
looted in the 19th century in the 19th
century the the war there was laws and
the Looting of war was legal maybe it's
not moral but it's legal and if you want
to come back on this why don't you come
back the 19th century 17th century 16th
century
you cannot stop you don't know where to
stop okay so how do I explain this so
that that man will understand yes that
may not have been lows explicitly making
looting illegal but the idea that that
gives you carte blanche is how you say
OS sheet and setting aside that Didier
reichner the Looting apologist art
historian seems less like a real person
and more like a character intent in how
he saved the Egyptians from themselves
the fact is looting wasn't just an
acceptable unavoidable byproduct of War
under Zulu it was sometimes baked into
the plan from the outset in fact John
notorious British raid in Northern
Ethiopia in 1868 the Army even brought
along an expert from the British museum
to bid for some of the choicest items
and importantly people knew the practice
was wrong even back then after that
radon Ethiopia the British prime
minister said he deeply lamented for the
sake of the country and for the sake of
all concerned that these articles were
thought fit to be brought Away by a
British Army and urged that they'd be
held only until they could be restored
and he was saying that in 1868 we didn't
even know how to fix a UTI without
leeches back then but we knew that
raiding other countries for their [ __ ]
was deeply lamentable which is British
for super [ __ ] up
now the second common argument is that
objects are actually safer under the
care of Western institutions than they
would be in their home country here is
that case being made by an art dealer
regarding pre-columbian art from Peru
according to the law
which I think like to think of as
Solomon's law
the one who loves the baby best gets the
baby the one who'll pay the most for the
baby gets the baby
if Peru cannot properly take care of its
National Treasures
the rest of the world will take care of
it for the peruvius as it should be
that man seems great but you know what
you know what he is right it's exactly
as King Solomon famously declared the
real mother is whoever agrees to offer
200 000 over the asking price all cash
inspection waived
but that argument you can't be trusted
with your own property you'll just
damage it it's hard to land even before
you learn that the caretaking record of
some museums is mixed at best remember
that woman insisting that the Greeks
couldn't possibly take care of the
Parthenon marbles here is a fun fact
multiple leaks have been reported in the
British Museum's Greek Galleries and in
the 1930s in what museum officials later
admitted was a heavy-handed attempt to
clean the sculptures they actively
damaged them by scrubbing them with wire
brushes and a harsh cleaning agent to
look even under Solomon's law whoever
loves the baby gets the baby but if you
scrub the baby with water brushes we
take the [ __ ] baby away
and the final argument that you hear is
that these museums are an open
repository of the world's treasures and
can actually increase the number of
people who can enjoy them but you've
already seen someone point out that is
only true if you can get to the museum
in question and also it's worth noting
that most display only a tiny fraction
of their collections the British museum
for instance has a collection of 8
million objects although only around 80
000 of them just one percent are on
public display at any one time and it
can be pretty galling for people to find
that their Heritage which is often part
of a vibrant present day culture is
sitting in storage in the British
Museum's underground loot prison
here in the U.S we've stashed away many
Native American artifacts and just watch
as members of the east of Shoshone and
Northern Arapahoe tribes are allowed to
visit artifacts in storage at Chicago's
Field Museum so just beyond here is the
storeroom where we'll be looking at some
of the artifacts
when I think about
objects that belong to tribal members
that are just sitting there in the dark
I felt angry
and I felt sad
just walk in and there's just like
rows and rows and rows of all these
objects
they've been boxed away since they were
collected
nobody can see them
touch them
be around them
that is devastating and it gets a lot
harder to pretend that these objects are
fulfilling a mission of educating and
connecting people when they're in a
basement in a box labeled with a [ __ ]
Sharpie and at this point you may well
be thinking well obviously we shouldn't
have taken those objects in the past but
now we know better but you should know
this practice is still very much going
on which brings us to the second big
part of our story The Modern Antiquities
Market because items are still being
bought sold and donated all the time
between private individuals museums
dealers and auction houses and when it
comes to those items the key word to
understand is provenance basically the
full history of an object and the path
it took to end up here because not every
piece is like those famous Benin bronzes
where it is clear from our history books
who took them for most items Research
into Providence is absolutely critical
it's not just how you know whether an
item is real or fake but also whether or
not it got to you legally the auction
house Sotheby's in even as a whole video
on its website bragging about how much
it loves researching provenance even
though it seems to view it as less an
ethical imperative and more as a pretty
sweet marketing perk so provenance
that's my favorite part provenance is
the history of ownership for a work
since it was brought to life who that
work of art had been made for whose
walls it's been hanging on how many
different hands has it passed through
who else has looked at it in some cases
who else has loved it who wore it and
when did she wear it how did she wear it
how often did she wear it for me this is
what we kind of live for is to get the
great stories to tell and often the
story of its ownership can be just as
interesting if not more interesting than
the artist promise is something that in
a way doesn't matter and yet
yet yeah and yet in another way it
really does a quick side note never in
my life has there been such an
intimidatingly bougie collection of
people you can almost hear them saying
actually it's pronounced quas Hall and
well I do not doubt the Sotheby's loves
backstories that add luster and
crucially value to the objects that they
auctioned they and many others seem much
less interested when those stories
uncover something seemier one Gallery
owner who recently pled guilty for her
part in trafficking looted Antiquities
said that buying and selling objects
with vague or even no provenance was so
much the norm in the Art Market it was a
conspiracy of the willing and to see
exactly what that conspiracy can look
like just look at one attempted sale
where Sotheby's ignore some pretty
glaring warning signs three years ago
Cambodia learned that Sotheby's auction
house in Manhattan was attempting to
sell a thousand-year-old masterpiece for
three million dollars the feet of which
were are still at the temple in Cambodia
Sotheby's was warned by the very expert
they hired to appraise the statue that
it was quote definitely stolen they knew
the feet were still there despite what
their expert told them they decided to
put the statue on the front of one of
their more prominent auction catalogs of
the year holy [ __ ] how did that
conversation go the expert said this is
definitely stolen and sotheby said yeah
but it might not be right and the Expo
said no it is stolen and suddenly said
you're so funny and the expert said I'm
sorry what and so to be said seriously
Jamie you're too much and the Expo said
thanks but again it is stolen and
suddenly said tell your mama said hi and
the expert said my mom's actually dead
and then they printed it on the cover
now legally I have to tell you Sotheby's
insist that they did nothing wrong and
that they conduct extensive due
diligence before offering items up for
auction but you should know in the case
of that statue Federal prosecutors
eventually intervened forcing Sotheby's
to hand it over to Cambodia where it was
eventually happily reunited with its
feet it's a real Cinderella Story isn't
it if Cinderella had been amputated at
the ankle
and interestingly and to that point it
is not uncommon to see statues missing
feet or hands and while you might assume
that it's damage due to time it's often
a sign that it has been stolen with
looters or thieves soaring off heads to
sell separately or hacking a sculpture
out from the temple wore so rapidly that
they leave the feet behind and if I know
this and you now know this then
Sotheby's definitely [ __ ] did and
again this is why provenance research is
so vitally important but many buyers
fail to do even the bare minimum meaning
that the demand for stolen goods will
always be met by a steady supply just
watch as a dealer in Nepalese artifacts
Deepak shakia basically walk someone
through just how easy it can be to get
paperwork to justify removing an object
from the country by law the country's
Department of archeology cannot issue
export papers on items more than a
hundred years old
but Deepak says he has a tried and
proven way
so government no problem getting these
out I mean we have to give some money to
undertale otherwise no problem
I mean it's not legal okay but still I
mean we can get this time it's no
problem okay that is way too easy I
don't know how hard it should be to
illegally export a culture's treasured
Antiquities but it should at least be
harder than find a guy who has a guy
that man was later arrested and charged
presumably alarming any museums with
large collections from Nepal and just
look what happened when those
documentary makers sat down with a
representative from the Reuben Museum
right here in New York to ask a pretty
basic question in Nepal authorities
recently
arrested
a number of antique dealers
has the Reuben Museum done any dealings
with Deepak shakia or his family the
shakias
I don't think we should answer that to
me the Museum's PR person intervenes
you have to do a lot of research to know
that okay
do you want us to like get back to
practice that would be yeah that'd be
good
a pretty good rule when you're asked do
you work with art thieves is there any
answer that's not an immediate no is
instantly suspicious and while the
Reuben later claimed that to their best
knowledge they didn't have any
connection to Deepak shakia or any
objects from him they did return these
two objects from their collection just
this year that were very much stolen and
The Nepalese group that pressured them
to do that recently identified another
object that they say is stolen which you
will never guess just happens to be in
the Rubin right now but don't worry the
Reuben told us they're looking into that
one now too and I'm sure they'll get
back to us after all it's what they do
and the thing is there are lots of
dealers around who use museums to
launder their reputations take subash
Kapoor he was once one of the leading
sources of Asian arts for museums and
collectors the Met currently has 86
objects from him in its collection and
even through a private reception in 2009
after he donated dozens of Indian
drawings which was a real win win
because the Met got the drawings and
Kapoor got to tell people that he had
art in the met and it's not like they
would work with a disreputable dealer
right but Kapoor was ultimately
identified as a prolific trafficker of
stolen goods and he didn't even bother
coming up with good cover Stories the
most common one that he used was the
objects had come from the family
collection of his girlfriend and you
might be thinking that is so stupid it
would only work on a group of real ding
dongs to which I'd say you're absolutely
right it seems to have worked on the Met
86 times
and buying art without doing proper
provenance research can blow up in a
Museum's face in spectacular fashion
take what happened a few years back at
the Met Gala the Year 2018. Kim
Kardashian made an appearance wearing
head to toe Atelier Versace that was
notably gold just like this guy nejamanc
or more specifically his coffin which
the Met had recently acquired guys a
photo op of the two of them had to
happen didn't it well when it did the
internet absolutely exploded but then
this happened
the Metropolitan Museum of Art New York
receiving a tip after Kim's photo from
the Met Gala went viral the Manhattan
assistant district attorney was emailed
the photo by an anonymous informant in
the Middle East saying he recognized the
coffin and knew it had been looted
Museum officials saying they bought the
sarcophagus for 4 million dollars from
an art dealer in Paris in 2017 but were
fooled by fake paper saying it had been
legitimately exported decades ago wow
say what you like about Kim Kardashian
the woman has a real knack for producing
incredible images just by standing next
to men that looked like they died a long
time ago
now it turns out it turns out
nature mom's coffin had been stolen
during the Egyptian Uprising in 2011 and
as the story unraveled it became very
clear that the Met should have been a
lot more suspicious when it was offered
to them because the red flags included
three conflicting ownership histories
the involvement of known traffickers and
a forged export license to board the
stamp Arab Republic of Egypt before the
country used that name and that is too
many red flags even like if Madame two
swords bought and displayed a clearly
alive James Spader your only job was to
make sure this celebrity was waxed how'd
you [ __ ] this up so badly let the man go
home
now the Met has since relinquished the
coffin and apologized to Egypt but a
Museum's approach to Providence research
cannot be do nothing until Kim
Kardashian takes a photograph in front
of one of our objects and we're
humiliated on the international stage
this cannot be all her responsibility
she's too busy revolutionizing shapewear
and it's worth it's worth noting in the
last five years the metas had no fewer
than nine search warrants executed on it
resulting in 37 pieces being seized and
none of this is a victimless crime
because the trafficking of looted
Antiquities has financed some of the
world's worst actors from the genocidal
Khmer Rouge in Cambodia to the Islamic
State in Iraq and Syria and the harm
also extends to the personal level
because again if I could impress one
thing on you it's that when these
objects end up in the west we put them
behind glass and we call them art but in
their home contexts they can be much
more for instance this stolen sacred
statue was in a Dallas Museum until
March of last year and when it was
finally returned to Nepal it was
immediately put back into use for
religious worship there was just a level
of abject callousness on display here
which to be fair some institutions are
finally coming to terms with take the
University of Aberdeen in school
Scotland it recently began reassessing
objects in its collection and facing the
Grim realities of what it had been
holding on to like this glass sphere now
the story behind how it got to Aberdeen
is both fascinating and completely
horrifying
this Hindu holy man had been challenged
to hold the glass Sphere for 12 years in
order to obtain a beneficial afterlife
he only managed eight subsequently we
discovered that in the anatomical
collection of human skulls
we have his skull wow is that his hair
tattoos yeah let's have a look
gosh that's him amazing
and
awful at the same time isn't it they're
cremated are they Hindus and he hasn't
been animated that's profoundly
offensive isn't it and here we are in
the 21st century and we still have how
many put this person to rest no
God that's terrible isn't it yeah it is
and for about a hundred different
reasons because a head in a box is less
something you'd expect to find at an
academic institution and more in the
basement of a [ __ ] serial killer and
that's emblematic of so much here the
fact that for so long not only did no
one see the significance of that object
to that man no one saw that man as
significant period
so what can be done well some
institutions like the University of
Aberdeen have been taking this Reckoning
seriously they are beginning discussions
with our local Hindu temple about what
to do with that man's remains they
actually also had a Benin bronze which
they repatriated late last year which is
great but too often the Reckoning only
goes so far a few years ago the UK's
National Army museum returns to Ethiopia
a stolen lock of hair belonging to an
Ethiopian Emperor but took pains to
point out that it was and I quote
definitely not a precedent look the fact
is museums should be getting asked hard
questions about every aspect of both
their acquisition process and their
collections as part of a long overdue
conversation about where their items
came from and whether anyone wants them
back you know some countries might even
be willing to loan items back out to
museums around the world but with a
clear understanding of who actually owns
them the point is that conversation
should be led by by the groups of those
items originally belong to because while
obviously museums should not be
violating the law they shouldn't be
violating basic moral decency either
there is so much that we need to do to
reckon with the harms both past and
present of colonialism but this should
really be the easy part and until such
time as we genuinely engage in that
Reckoning I'd actually like to present a
potential Plan B
hi I'm Kamel nanjiani and I'm here to
introduce you to the payback Museum the
the first Public Museum in the world
devoted to providing recourse to Nations
who've been plundered of the greatest
treasures throughout history by Colonial
[ __ ]
The Collection that's all about
disconnecting people specifically
disconnecting Western countries from
their [ __ ] you know the way they did to
everyone else
Welcome to our Africa
B Benin bronzes the spectacular tablets
that tell the comprehensive story of a
glorious Kingdom
but they were put in the back shaking
and dumped out all over Europe like a
bunch of Scrabble letters so until we
get them back this room is home too one
of the Stonehenge arches
yeah Britain you might have noticed
you're missing one we took it because
you were just leaving it out letting it
get wet I mean look there's like grass
and [ __ ] on it and frankly we can't even
think about returning it until you start
caring for what you already have
honestly I don't even like it I think
Stonehenge sucks it's just big dumb
rocks but I don't want to return them to
spite you are you having fun I am let's
move on you're not with Latin America
Wing we wanted to feature a collection
of gorgeous ancient indigenous Peruvian
textiles but they're all in the museum
in Philadelphia so instead we have
Liberty Bell an early American example
of a [ __ ] Bell and we didn't stop
there we also have Mark Rushmore to be
more accurate just the tip and to be
more specific of George Washington's
nose
and you might be thinking why are you
depriving thousands of bored school
children the sight of this oversized
snoz and this [ __ ] up Dinger well you
know the rules whoever loves the baby
best gets the baby and your babies got
got now we've got something really
special I'm thrilled to announce the
grand opening of our brand new
state-of-the-art Asia Wing where we are
Beyond proud to display a number of
Priceless 10th Century religious statues
or at least we were now we only have
their feet
so instead we got a couple things from
France
oh we got most of the Mona Lisa
overrated bunch of [ __ ] from Versailles
Eugene delacroix Liberty Leading the
People which I swear we're gonna frame
at some point or at least get some
poster putty tack it onto a wall like in
a college dorm room next to a picture of
Bob Marley
you know what's fun the story of its
ownership can be just as interesting as
the art itself who's owned it who's
loved it who you'll stop as we run out
of the museum with it if that would
happen which it definitely didn't
because we have the papers saying it's
fine see don't worry we followed all the
lows now if you come with me our last
stop is where the real Treasures are
here we are in the storeroom where we
keep some of our most prized possessions
items so valuable we know it's morally
indefensible for us to have them the
free one of these boxes here will blow
your mind we've got loot more loot oh
this one's very very special
in this box like three of Gerald Ford's
ribs you're wondering why do we have
three of Gerald Ford's ripped it's
because we could not get four and you're
probably thinking wait he hasn't been
dead nearly long enough for that to be
okay and I say oh yeah
how long do you have to be dead for it
to be okay huh I'm serious give me a
number for how long after his death it's
okay to have a part of someone's body
sweating in your Museum's hot storage
hmm
so please if you're from one of the
countries that own this stuff come enjoy
it our museum is a world repository so
you can visit your stuff anytime between
9 am and 4pm and not on Mondays and I
know you might want some of this stuff
back and we would love to give it back
to you but if we give it to you everyone
else is going to line up and suddenly
this whole place is empty so the answer
is no
it's all ours forever
[Music]
hmm smells like Payback
rib dust
that's our show thanks so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night